[Music]
if you've seen some of my videos
you've probably briefly seen this before
wondering what is going on
people deep within the breath of the
wild community have heard of it and
known of it since september 2020
yet only whispers appear here and there
and even the most seasoned glitch
hunters barely attempt this ridiculous
glitch
which makes you wonder why this hasn't
been looked into it's because you'll
probably be incredibly frustrated trying
to do it
it's called super menu overload
[Music]
there have been thousands of glitches
and discoveries in breath of the wild in
the past four
years larger fines such as wind bombs
and memory storage which completely bend
the game engine
or allow you to attain weapons otherwise
impossible to get seem to get a lot of
attention of casual and hardcore fans
alike but even though super menu
overload has the ability to literally
freeze time and projectiles in place
have objects and limbs go missing and
throw a storm of weapons in 5 seconds
no one talks about it let me explain why
first
because there is barely any community
research on this glitch i'm going to try
to explain super menu overload
in my way that's easy to digest breath
of the wild's performance is intertwined
between two things
memory which is how many objects are in
a certain area such as bushes
trees weapons npcs etc and additional
processing such as npcs walking around
metallic items getting conducted or
objects swaying in the wind
a simple in-game example of this is
korok forest where simply looking around
causes the game to lag because of the
sheer amount of grass
koroks trees and bushes the game has the
process to animate to sway in the wind
but what happens if you put hundreds of
objects into the game that are just
sitting there not moving or causing
additional stress on the game
the game does lag a tiny bit but since
you're not actually doing anything
the game runs fine this is the core
behind super menu overloading which
keeps the processing load
down while pushing its memory limits
extremely high this is proven by having
a pile of duplicated weapons on the
ground where by itself it doesn't seem
to affect the game too much
but as soon as you run an electric
current through it the game's frame rate
takes a heavy nose dive
trying to process electric effects
through 100 weapons it just touched
so the general idea of super menu
overload is to push beyond that limit in
a low memory area
using menu overloading to duplicate
weapons and overload the switch's memory
all while keeping the game from crashing
you're probably then thinking
how many times do you have to duplicate
weapons to get to this point and the
answer is give or take
600 times yep you heard me right this
takes anywhere from 25 to 45
minutes depending on how much trouble
the process gave you and on top of that
if you want to perform the technique
that was on the very beginning of the
video it's another five to ten minutes
on top of that
this is why even the most dedicated
glitch hunters would rather not even
attempt this because even with this
proven method being found
every time you do it isn't going to be
exactly the same that's right it's not
even consistent
and the unstable nature of this glitch
still makes the game crash a lot because
you're constantly teetering on the
limits of the game engine's capabilities
this means many attempts up to 45
minutes of duplicating weapons is wasted
as when you crash you start all over
again for this video i've duplicated
somewhere around 10
800 weapons for capturing examples
testing and retrying failed attempts
all to make this project happen
this is not for the faint of heart and
is arguably one of the most painstaking
glitches to perform in breath of the
wild
next to memory storage that said there's
one japanese user by the name of noho
who has performed this glitch hundreds
of times
and has recommended the most consistent
method to perform this glitch so
if you want to challenge yourself at
home here's how to do it but be warned
if you do not have any experience with
menu overloading first
this may be incredibly difficult for you
or if you're just curious about this
ridiculous process i'll show you how it
works
[Music]
first come to this location in osira
plains as this area never rains and has
very few
objects in the surrounding area this is
important because storms cause a heavy
load on your game and cause you to crash
and having fewer objects in the area
makes your process much smoother and
much more consistent
to start you'll need five to six
multi-shot bows to perform a regular
menu overload but i recommend having a
couple extra
if you don't know how to do this you'll
want to look up youtube tutorials for
that
then comes the next part duplication
[Music]
this can be performed with most weapons
but you'll want to shy away from any
elemental or most ancient weapons
as their flashy effects have an
additional load on the game and cause
you to crash
much more easily we personally recommend
the royal halberd and the world guard
spear
as these weapons are not as taxing on
the game and keep the framerate
relatively high
this is performed by switching to
another weapon then throwing it
causing the weapon to be thrown to the
ground but it never leaves your
inventory because you technically had a
different weapon equipped
now do this around 600 times this is
much easier said than done
as during the process the weapons will
sometimes randomly not start to appear
in your hands
stop desyncing
or the desync pattern will change
this can be fixed by unequipping a bow
or shield on your back to draw weapons
again
spamming bow and weapon to force the
game to desync again and dropping and
picking up the bow to reboot the desync
process
like i stated earlier every attempt can
have different problems and this
inconsistent nature is what makes this
glitch difficult
remember to pause or take breaks if
you're getting tired
once you get to around the 600 weapon
mark you'll want to start paying
attention to link's hands you know
you've achieved super menu overload when
link reads to throw but there's nothing
in his hands
if you see this congratulations you've
finally achieved your goal
in this state there can be varying
effects such as arrows staying in place
body parts that go missing or even
different effects with different
duplicated weapons such as bullet time
on open ground
but now you're wondering how did you do
that throwing trick against the lionel
well prepare to throw even more and
attempt something called throw gatling
first let's explain what we've done so
far with an analogy let's imagine
building a dam with a reservoir
first menu overloading and duplicating
weapons is a damn building process
once the supermenu overload is achieved
the dam is done and ready to hold water
throwing weapons past the 600 weapon
mark throws the item but it never
appears
these invisible weapons are the rising
reservoir filling with water
they're being held in place and staying
until you let go like a real dam if you
throw too many weapons into this buffer
which in this case is 99 additional
weapons the game will crash
aka the dam will break but if you throw
the weapon safely then perform an action
that will release the weapons all at
once
it will be a controlled release of water
through floodgates or in this case
thrown weapons just like a dam releasing
its floodgates
this is called throw gatling like i
stated before this is still inconsistent
and has many underlying rules
but this is the most successful method
perform your superman
overload here then once you know that
it's active run up to the lynel here
make sure to run up to it then pull out
your weapon to make it perform its
explosion attack
don't worry you'll be fine
[Music]
this attacks fireball requires too much
memory to perform
so when it smacks the ground it freezes
unable to move
this is when you start your throw
gatling process by simply throwing two
weapons over and over right next to the
lynel
two savage lino swords seem to have the
least crashes in our experience
remember you cannot throw more than 99
weapons once you've done enough throwing
damage to kill the lynel
hold zl to engage the rook's protection
and unequip whatever equipment you have
on you
sit back and enjoy the fireworks
rest of the world continues to have a
myriad of secrets even four years after
release
and the discovery of new glitches keeps
the game constantly fresh
even if some of these finds are
painstaking if you enjoyed this or at
least found it interesting give us a
like we continue to show what new things
you can do breath of the wild to this
day
and for everything else stay tuned right
here on gamespot
you